we marked the 75th anniversary of the
arrival of the Empire Windrush tomorrow
I'm sure the whole house will celebrate
the contribution of the Windrush
generation who have done so much to
build the Britain that we cherish today
and Mr Speaker this on forces week we
thank them for all they do to keep our
country safe this morning I had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today Patricia Gibson
speaker as inflation continues to
outstrip Pearl worms and tomorrow we
expect to see the 13th consecutive rise
in interest rates will the Prime
Minister tell the house by how much
living standards have fallen during his
eight months in office
[Music]
well Mr Mr Speaker I've always been very
clear inflation is putting pressure on
family budgets and that's why the UK
government has taken decisive action to
support families through this difficult
time including households in Scotland
who are receiving considerable support
not just with their energy bills but
also the most vulnerable as well well
Benji thank you Mr Speaker on this side
of the house we've got a pro director
that supported the nuclear industry
which is an essential part of achieving
secure low carbon energy I'm delighted
to the very honorable friend the Prime
Minister has given us back into the next
generation of nuclear reactors including
SMR and larger projects and ask the Eno
commits to seeing the fuel for these
projects manufactured in the UK this
will secure long-term High skilled
employment at Key sites in the Northwest
like Springfield to my constituency and
the supply chain across the UK
Mr Speaker we are preserving and
strengthening the UK's nuclear fuel
production capacity through our 75
billion pound nuclear Fuel Fund I know
that Springfield fuels in my honorable
friends constituency has benefited from
30 million pounds of funding and he's
right to say that our domestic nuclear
fuel sector has a critical role to play
in supporting the UK's energy security
and Independence and I know that he will
continue to be a champion for the
industry in this house welcome to the
leader of the opposition
thank you Mr Speaker can I join the
Prime Minister and his comments about
the Windrush generation who've
contributed so much to our country and
to the armed forces in this week and all
weeks and Glenda Jackson's passing
leaves a space in our cultural and
political life that could never be
filled she played many roles with great
distinction passion and commitment
Academy award-winning actor campaigning
labor MP and an Effective Government
Minister we will never see Talent like
hers again
Mr Speaker one of the
one of them's own MPS says Britain is
facing a mortgage catastrophe
does he agree with her
Mr Speaker can I start by joining The
Honorable gentleman in his uh tribute to
Glenda Jackson uh and Mr Speaker it's
also right that we do support those with
the mortgages and this is why the
absolute right economic priority is to
halve inflation because inflation is
what is driving interest rates up
inflation is what erodes people's
savings and pushes up prices and
ultimately makes them poorer now this is
why a long time before I had this job I
highlighted the importance of tackling
inflation it's why that I said it is
never easy to root out inflation but we
will take the difficult and responsible
decisions to do so it's an approach that
the IMF has it strongly endorsed in
their words and describing our actions
as decisive and responsible
Mr Speaker I realized the promise to
spend all week saying he doesn't want to
influence anyone or anything it was
certainly keeping to that with his
answer
he knows very well the cause of the
mortgage catastrophe yeah 13 years of
economic failure and a Tory Kamika
McCarter which crashed the economy and
put mortgages through the roof
so will the Prime Minister tell us how
much the Tory mortgage penalty is going
to cost the average homeowner
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Mr Speaker as ever The
Honorable gentleman isn't aware of the
global macroeconomic situation but let
me do
[Applause]
substantively what I what let me tell
here man the house what we are doing to
support those with mortgages we have
deliberately and proactively increased
the generosity of our support for the
mortgage interest scheme we've also
established a new FCA Community Duty
which will protect people with mortgages
for example moving them on to
interest-only mortgages or lengthening
mortgage terms and we have spent tens of
billions of pounds supporting people
with the cost of living particularly the
most vulnerable but that is the
difference between us Mr Speaker while
he is always focused on the politics we
are actually just getting on and doing
the job
Let's test that because the question he
refuses to answer he actually knows the
answer this question is 2 900 pounds
extra that's the cost to the average
family of the Tory mortgage penalty now
he was warned by experts about this as
long ago as Autumn last year but he
either didn't get it didn't believe it
or didn't care because he certainly
didn't do anything yeah and when I
raised this a couple of months ago he
had the goal to stand at that dispatch
box and say he was delivering for
homeowners
how is an extra 2 900 pounds a year of
repayment delivering for homeowners
well so Mr speaker now let's just let's
just
could explain why interest rates are at
similar levels in the United States in
Canada in Australia and New Zealand why
they're at the highest level in Europe
that they've been
decades Mr Speaker that's why it's
important that we have a plan to reduce
inflation but in contrast what do we
hear from one more gentlemen he wants to
punctuation worse he wants to ban new
supplies of energy from the naughty that
would make the situation worse and and
he wants to give in to Union's
unaffordable pay demands that would make
the situation worse Mr Speaker he
doesn't have many policies but the few
that he does have all have the same
thing in common they're dangerous
inflationary and working people would
pay the price
foreign
sorry
I don't think we need any more do we no
okay summer read Mr Speaker has a keen
interest in the mortgage Market in
California but I'm talking about movie
told us here
and whilst his government is consumed in
law breaking chaos and division working
people are paying the price
this morning I spoke to James in Selby
he's a police officer working hard to
keep people safe every day the Tory
mortgage penalty is going to cost him
and his family 400 pounds more each and
every month that's nearly 5 000 pounds
he told me this morning they may not
want to hear this he told me this
morning
that they've decided to sell their house
to downsize and he's just told his
children they're going to have to start
sharing bedrooms
why should James and his family pay the
cost of the prime minister's failure
well Mr Mr Speaker I hope when The
Honorable gentleman was talking to James
he explained that his economic policies
would make James's situation worse Mr
it's not just me saying that Mr Speaker
the independent the independent
Institute of fiscal studies says his
policy of never-ending debt and
borrowing would damage change because it
would increase inflation and drive up
interest rates leaving James and
everybody else in this country horror Mr
Speaker the IMF has said that our plan
prioritizes not what is politically easy
but what is right for the British people
that is what responsible economic
leadership looks like Mr Speaker
about it
James and his family will have been
listening to that prime minister
a mere polite should keep them awake at
night because over the next few years
7.5 million people are going to be in
the same boat
all paying the Tory mortgage penalty
months after month after month
the situation is so dire that
repossessions are already up 50 a total
betrayal of the idea that if you work
hard you'll get on
so what's the Prime Minister going to do
to make sure more families don't lose
their homes
[Applause]
yes sir that I gave well I did it I did
actually spell out in detail what we are
doing Mr Speaker we've increased the
generosity of support for mortgage
interest scheme we did that proactively
in advance we've also established a new
FDA consumer Duty that will protect
borrowers for example by allowing them
to extend their mortgage terms or switch
to interest-only mortgages and we have
spent tens of billions of pounds
supporting households with living costs
those are the practical steps that we
are taking to help James and other
families who are facing these situations
but what I would say because he
mentioned mortgage arrears and uh
repossessions I am pleased to say Mr
Speaker they are actually running at a
level today that is below when we enter
the pandemic Mr Speaker because of the
actions that we're taking but more
importantly than that perhaps Mr Speaker
is that they are also running three
times lower than the level We inherited
from the last Labor government
yourself
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I'm sure from the
vantage point of his helicopter
everything might look fine but that's
not the lived experience of those on the
ground after 13 years of economic
failure across the country people are
paying the price of uncosted Reckless
damaging Decisions by the Tory party and
even now as mortgages go through the
roof the prime minister is planning to
wave through honors and peerages for
those who cause misery for Millions
what does it say about this government
that while working people are worrying
about mortgage hype paying the bills
even repositions the Tory party is
rewarding those guilty of economic
vandalism
Mr Speaker no amount of personal attacks
and Petty Point scoring can disguise the
fact that the honorable gentleman does
not have a plan for this country Mr
Speaker
[Music]
[Applause]
yes Mr Speaker inflation is the
challenge that's why we are on track to
keep reducing it we are reducing
weightiness we are stopping the boats
all while he is focused on the past
focused on the politics it's all talk
whereas from this government and from
this prime minister we deliver for the
country
Vegas
Philip I know you're popular come on
thank you very much Mr Speaker my
constituents continue to be concerned
about energy prices and energy security
uh will the Prime Minister assure me
that he will not cave in to the
extremist bullies from just stop oil
this is on the labor leadership
and instead commit and instead commit to
developing new oil and gas production in
the United Kingdom which will be good
for jobs good for the economy and make
us less dependent on foreign countries
for our energy Supply
well as ever my honorable friend makes
an excellent point Putin's weaponization
of energy has Amplified the need for
greater energy security and that's why
we deliberately have launched new
licensing rounds for the naughty
official forecasts suggests that a block
on naughty oil and gas investment would
mean that the UK is dependence on
Imports would rise substantially Mr
Speaker the labor party's decision is
one that puts ideology ahead of jobs
investment and Britain's energy security
SMP leader Stephen Flynn
Mr Speaker in February the Prime
Minister told this year hosts that
borrowing costs are back to where they
should be in March he boasted we are on
track to have inflation by the end of
the year and me he then said economic
optimism is increasing well given the
dire economic reality of today's and not
now clear that he's taken his honesty
lessons from Boris Johnson
[Music]
well Mr Mr Speaker the The Honorable
gentleman also failed to mention that
not just the bank of England not just
the obr not just the oecd but also the
IMF all of them have upgraded their
growth outlet for the United Kingdom
economy this year whilst he and others
were predicting that this country would
enter a recession the actions of this
government have meant that we have so
far averted that and we continue to be
on track to keep reducing inflation
because that is the right economic
priority can I just say I want people to
be a little bit more cautious on what
they say this is the present serving
prime minister the digital it could be
misled in the way that it was put
Stephen Flynn yeah Mr Speaker listening
to the prime minister's answer I don't
think he quite grasps the reality of the
economic situation facing households
across since I also how kitty but it
doesn't need to be like this it didn't
need to be like this because mortgage
deals in Ireland they're not sitting in
excess of six percent they're around
about four and a half percent inflation
in the Euro area that's not setting at
8.7 percent it's set in a closer to six
percent Britain is broke now seven years
after their EU referendum well he
finally admit that it was brexit that
broke it
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker again I don't think the
honorable gentleman was paying attention
earlier interest rates in this country
are at similar levels so they are in
America in Canada in Australia and in
New Zealand Mr Speaker the rise in
inflation and interest rates is the
global phenomenon but that's why early I
set out that it was the right economic
priority to have to bring inflation down
that's what this government would do but
that requires Mr Speaker that requires
difficult and responsible decisions
that's what leadership looks like I
don't think the s p will ever do the
same thing Virginia Crosby
honest more is recognized as the best
site for small modular reactors and
large
[Applause]
UK
when can my unsworn constituents expect
to hear the result of Great British
nuclear small modular reactor
competition yeah
well Mr Speaker there'll be no greater
Champion for this technology and her
community The Honorable friend and my
understanding is that the first stage of
Market engagement is already underway
the expectation is that the down
selection process will be launched this
summer with an ambition to assess and
decide on the leading Technologies this
Autumn their competition will be open
judicious fair and robust and I express
uh all my confidence that we will select
the best technology for the United
Kingdom I'm just welcoming it right
Stephen Fury
four months after the very welcome
Windsor framework there is still no
restored Northern Ireland executive or
assembly and we are facing an
unprecedented budget crisis this
situation is untenable it's getting
worse every day and the government
approach seems to be to wait to see if
something happens rather than leading
from the front so counter prime minister
confirmed that he's willing to work with
Northern parties on a financial package
for a restored executive and also really
work closely with the Irish government
to try to drive a process including
putting reformed with institutions on
the agenda so those who want the
government can do so
Mr Speaker can I thank the uh honorable
gentleman for his engagement with me in
the government during this process I
share his frustration and our Focus
remains on delivering for the people of
Northern Ireland to expect and deserve
their locally elected decision makers to
address the issues that matter to them
most I thank him for his kind words
about the Windsor framework and how it
allows us to move forward and for many
years we have recognized the challenges
particularly facing Northern Ireland and
that's why we've provided over 7 billion
pounds of funding on top of the Barnet
block grant since 2014. I can assure him
the right my right and will friend the
Northern Ireland secretary remains in
close contact with all the parties in
Northern Ireland to clarify what more is
needed so that we can restore the
conditions for executive formation we've
got to learn Fox thank you Mr Speaker
since 2016 cumulative growth in Italy
has been four percent in Germany has
been 5.5 in the UK has been 6.8 percent
in me last year British export to the
European Union were not just the high
since brexit but since records began the
UK had the highest growth of any G7
country in both 2021 and 2022 the
Eurozone is currently in recession we
are not is it not time we had more good
news talking Britain out
well
my uh my writable friend my right
honorable friend is quite right to
highlight the improvement in our
economic Outlook and his right to
highlight the good positive news showing
the strength in the underlying economy
and I know that he joins with me in
saying that our economic priority right
now must be to continue to Bear Down on
inflation but while we do that we are
putting the conditions in place to grow
this economy and as he said unlike the
party opposite we won't talk Britain
down we will grow the country's jobs
Mr Speaker last night was another
fantastic night at Hampden a real tonic
during tough times
and Scotland more wildly however most
English and Welsh fans could watch the
national teams for free on Channel 4 and
s4c only a small fraction of Scots could
watch the match with it with many unable
to afford its subscription to Via play
particularly during this course to live
any crisis so this is me this is
inherently unfair and really ask the DC
dcms secretary to meet with me to
discuss how we fix our situation yeah
yeah
um well can I uh join with my honorable
friend in his comments uh about the
match and let him know that I know the
culture secretary is engaging with him
and others on this particular topic and
I'll make sure that she gets back to him
and Marie Morris
speaker in December last year link
conducted some research on cash
acceptance their research found that
nearly half 45 percent of people have
been somewhere where cash has not been
accepted or has been discouraged and 49
said being unable or being discouraged
to pay in cash was inconvenient will the
Prime Minister look again at the
financial services of Marcus bill when
it comes back from the other place and
ensure that any entity providing a
public service directly to the public
and involving payments or a child must
accept cash
[Music]
Mr Speaker we know that cash continues
to be used by millions of people
particularly those in vulnerable groups
and that's why the financial service and
markets Bill well for the first ever
time protect people's access to cash in
UK law the bill also supports businesses
to continue to accept cash by ensuring
reasonable access to deposit facilities
but as technology and consumer Behavior
changes it is right that organizations
themselves should be able to choose the
forms of payment that they will accept
thank you Mr Speaker
does the Prime Minister believe that the
reward for being a law breaker should be
to be made a lawmaker
[Music]
Mr Speaker there is as we discussed last
week a well-established process of
vetting for all for all garages and I in
Prime Ministers of both parties have
followed the same process
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker Wiltshire leads the
world in agritech the farming uh
increases in productivity that are going
to feed the world uh the world's growing
population without wrecking the
environment I welcome what the
government has done in this space
particularly in gene editing only
possible because of brexit of course
will my right honorable friend
acknowledge the work of Wiltshire
farmers and Tech entrepreneurs
particularly James Dyson but there are
many more yeah does he agree with me
this is one of the key opportunities for
our country to become a high-wage high
skill high-tech economy
Mr Speaker when it comes to agritech we
are among the best in the world with
fantastic research bodies businesses and
pioneering farmers and Growers and I
join my honorable friend in paying
tribute to all of them they're getting
all support with 270 million pound
farming Innovation program and as he
rightly mentioned we are seizing the
opportunities from our exit from the EU
including through our plans to more
quickly develop Gene edited crops that
are resistant to drought and flooding
that will drive up growth productivity
and create jobs Kevin blem thank you Mr
Speaker so just to recap during this
Parliament we've had one Tory prime
minister who turned out to be a proven
liar a second Tory prime minister who
was outlasted by a lettuce after this
week's pathetic no-show by the Prime
Minister what one word would he use to
describe himself might it be weak yeah
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker what's weak is the
party opposite being unable to stand up
is being able to stand up to the people
who fund them and stand behind
hard-working families in this country
[Music]
Mr Speaker
I welcome the steps the prime minister's
taking to stop illegal dangerous and
unnecessary Small Boat Crossings which
are overwhelming our Asylum system but I
have to raise significant concerns about
a recent decision to stand up a third
hotel in Burton as well as increase
capacity at another hotel by 64 percent
this is going to have a serious knock-on
effect for our response to homelessness
and rough sleeping as well as causing
challenges for wider public services in
East Staffordshire what further support
can the Prime Minister provide local
authorities in East Staffordshire to
deal with these urgent concerns
Mr Speaker this is why we need to stop
the boat so that we can relieve the
unsustainable pressure on our Asylum
system and accommodation Services which
is costing British taxpayers over three
billion pounds a year our new bill will
ensure that anyone arriving illegally
will be detained and swiftly removed but
in the meantime we will take action to
address the unacceptable costs of
housing migrants in hotels this we
recognize the pressure this place is on
local areas that's why central
government is providing further
dispersal financial support but I will
ensure that honorable friend gets a
meeting with the immigration minister to
discuss her specific local concerns
further and this Walter thank you very
much Mr Speaker Imperial NHS trust
described the government's recent
decision to delay the rebuilding of
Charing Cross Hammersmith and St Mary's
hospitals as hugely damaging for the
health and health care of hundreds of
thousands of people well the prime is to
keep the promise made to me by his
predecessor one year ago from that
dispatch box and guaranteed completion
of new hospitals on these sites by 20
30.
Mr Speaker the government remains
committed to two new hospital schemes
for Imperial College Health Care trust
at Hammer Smith Hospital in Charing
Cross hospital and for Saint Mary's
Hospital as part of the new hospital
program we've expanded the program as
The Honorable gentleman knows to include
buildings with rack and we need to
address those as a priority for the
safety of staff and patients however we
still expect the majority of schemes in
cohort for to be in construction before
2030 and I know that the department will
continue to keep him updated on progress
David Davis
Mr Speaker the United Kingdom Kingdom
sanctioned Iran for promoting terrorism
for destabilizing the Middle East for
supplying weapons to our enemies and of
course the proliferation of nuclear
weapons
within the past few weeks a journalist
David Rose has reported in the Jewish
Chronicle that British universities have
been undertaking research in
collaboration with Iranian researchers
and universities into areas potential
military applications including drone
technology fighter jets Battlefield
armor and Laser communication
will the Prime Minister initiate an
investigation into this and take action
to stop the failure of our sanctions
regime before it does any more harm to
the national interests of the United
Kingdom and our Ally
Mr Speaker I thank my honorable friend
for raising this important topic we take
all allegations of breaches of export
control seriously and my understanding
is that officials in the department for
business and trade are currently now
investigating the allegations made in
the recent press article cited we will
not accept collaborations which
compromise our national security and
that's why we've made our systems more
robust including expanding the scope of
the academic technology approval scheme
to protect UK research from
ever-changing Global threats the more
honorable friend is absolutely right to
highlight this and he has my Assurance
we will keep on it duplicate
could any of the material the prime
minister's government is trying to avoid
giving to the coveted inquiry cover his
tenure as Chancellor and his eat out to
help out policy yeah yeah well Mr
Speaker as I've said before I think it
is right that we learned the lessons
from kovid and that's why so that we can
be better prepared for the future and
that's why the government has cooperated
in a spirit of transparency in Canada
with the inquiry handing over more than
55 handing over more than 55
000 documents so far Mr Speaker that
there is a very specific point of
disagreement as The Honorable gentleman
well knows it is the subject now of
legal proceedings so I'm not able to
comment further Rexburg Mr Speaker
despite being world leaders in
Motorsport the UK has not hosted a round
of the World Rally Championship since
2019 we now have an opportunity to host
around in Northern Ireland next year to
bring in in excess of a hundred million
pounds to the economy but to make that
happen the promoters need government
underwriting of approximately a million
pounds so will my rightful friend the
Prime Minister agree with me that this
event simply must go ahead and instruct
the relevant departments to work with
the appg for Motorsport Motorsport UK
and the promoters to make it happen
well Mr Speaker Northern Ireland is a
fantastic place to host international
events and I'm delighted that my
honorable friend shares my enthusiasm
for driving forward prosperity in
Northern Ireland and with tourism though
being devolved in Northern Ireland I
suggest he engages with tourism ni on
this potential event and I look forward
to hearing how he gets on
weaker growth and a soaring inflation
according according to the former
government of the governor of the bank
of England the lse says how do you trade
barriers have added an average 250
pounds to household food bills and
Scott's fishing Chiefs are saying they
were sold down the river and scoff at
the talk of treaty renegotiation as just
spin with such colossal failures
stacking up and the former PM who played
a leading role in the league Camp
finally exposed as a serial liar will
the current PM apologize to my
constituents in Edinburgh North and Lee
yeah yeah Mr Speaker I I just point out
to The Honorable lady because she's
going on about the EU and US leaving it
we have actually we have actually grown
faster than France and Italy since we
left the single Market uh Mr Speaker our
exports have also grown by 25 just since
uh covid and as we heard from our
honorable friend earlier that every
single International Organization has
upgraded their forecast for UK economic
growth that's because we've got the
right priorities to drive growth create
jobs and spread opportunity in every
part of our United Kingdom thank you Mr
Speaker hospices across the UK provide
quality but also Compassionate Care to
people at the end of their lives such as
mountbatten Hospice in my constituency
who looked after my office manager Sue
Hall when she passed away in March
that's why I am her son-in-law miles
Rogers will be skydiving to raise money
on Saturday and we've raised six
thousand pounds so far the Prime
Minister should feel free to donate to
the campaign his best wishes to all
hospice workers across the United
Kingdom
well can I join with my honorable friend
first of all wishing I think it was
Miles good luck uh this weekend as he
raises money but also join him uh in
paying tribute to all our incredible
hospice volunteers and workers across
the country they do a fantastic job in
all our constituencies at a very
difficult time for families lives and we
all owe them an enormous amount of
thanks
okay half of us sadly will get cancer at
some point during our lives and half of
those with cancer will need radiotherapy
treatment yet three and a half million
people in this country live in
radiotherapy deserts where they don't
have close access to the treatment
including my constituency where my
patients living in Westland have to
travel three-hour round trips every day
to get life-saving treatments so would
the Prime Minister back our proposal for
a satellite radiotherapy unit at
Westland General Hospital in Kendall and
also helps put all the other members
living in the radiotherapy deserts to
bring radiotherapy close to their
communities too
well Mr Speaker I I know like The
Honorable gentleman that access to
Healthcare in rural areas is
particularly important given the
distances that our rural constituents
have to drive that's why we remain
committed to expanding the range of
diagnostic services that are available
through our proposal to roll out
Community diagnostic Centers and I think
the record-breaking capital budget that
we have in the NHS at the moment is
delivering that and I look forward to
the department engaging with him on his
plans for his local area their nature
thank you Mr Speaker as the bank of
England are raising interest rates to
try to stem spending and therefore
preventing inflation being baked into
the economy the same can't be said for
those with savings accounts and would it
not be a good for people to be
encouraged and incentivized to save more
and would my rant honorable friend and
the chancellor talk to the industry and
encourage them or impel them to actually
give a good deal to Savers too
can I thank my honorable friend because
she raises uh an excellent point it is
vitally important that Savers are
treated fairly and the markets are
functioning as competitively as we'd
expect them to be I'm pleased to tell
her that will run the chancellor
is meeting with the industry and the
banks this Friday to discuss the matter
that she's raised and will make sure
that she and everyone else gets an
update after that completes prime
minister's questions they'll let the
chamber player speaker
well that concludes this week's PM cues
lots of things on the agenda this week
as we expected but top really of the
agenda on which uh zakiastama was really
pushing the Prime Minister and the
government was of course cost of living
and particularly mortgage costs there
but before we get into the substance our
Deputy political editor samcos is still
here with me in the studio we've been
listening into it together
um before we get into the substance of
what we heard there let's talk a little
bit about the style the Prime Minister
looking distinctly irascible in some of
those extensions that's right it was an
uncomfortable prime minister's questions
for
Rishi sunak I thought mortgages of
course at the center of the discussion I
mean it it whether or not it's a
catastrophe that's the question that
that cures Dharma opened by asking
um that's a word by the way used by Tory
mp uh Lucy Allen uh the outgoing Telford
MP in a tweet last Friday uh or not it
is a very very big problem and we've
probably got we've probably got rate
risers tomorrow and so I was very
interested to look at how the Prime
Minister dealt with the questions from
Kirsten I I wonder whether or not it
isn't worth them in Downing Street
sitting down with him and re-watching
prime minister's questions because a
number of things struck in case they're
listening because a number of things
struck me about he he obviously was
quite he's angry he looked angry to me
you can see that whenever you see his
teeth you sort of know that he's quite
he's he's irritable and he's and and
what he does bad rasheeds and starts
lecturing people and there's quite a lot
of lecturing
absolutely it was a sort of he talked
about people not paying attention to
what he was saying and he talked about
kiss time and not understanding the
macroeconomic situation you know this is
a very big and bold and tricky issue for
every party there are no easy solutions
and I and I just wonder whether how that
tone uh where you're basically saying no
no no no you don't understand just just
whether that is is a particularly Prime
ministerial way I think at this point
where uh mortgages are raising so so far
so fast you know one individual a
policeman quoted uh by kirst armor 400
pounds a month let's hear some of the
way that kirst armor uh talked about the
problem
900 of the Tory mortgage penalty now he
was warned by experts about this as long
ago as Autumn last year but it either
didn't get it didn't believe it or
didn't care because he certainly didn't
do anything and when I raised this a
couple of months ago he had the goal to
stand at that dispatch box and say he
was delivering for homeowners how is an
extra 2 900 pounds a year of repayment
delivering for homeowners
[Applause]
because he talks about interest rates he
talks about interest rates perhaps all
gentlemen could explain why interest
rates are at similar levels in the
United States in Canada in Australia and
New Zealand why they're at the highest
level in Europe that they've been for
two decades Mr Speaker that's why it's
important that we have a plan to reduce
inflation but in contrast what do we
hear from one more gentlemen he wants to
an extra 28 billion pounds a year that
would make the situation worse he wants
to ban new supplies of energy from the
naughty that would make the situation
worse and and he wants to give in to
Union's unaffordable pay demands that
would make the situation worse Mr
Speaker he doesn't have many policies
but the few that he does have all have
the same thing in common they're
dangerous inflationary and working
people would pay the price
that's the response line we've seen
isn't it from the government before that
laborers you turned on their spending
plans they say that what what they're
planning it is not affordable but when
you get the leader of the opposition
saying 2 900 pounds a year that's what
sticks in people's minds isn't it it's
not
listening to arguments about exogenous
shocks and Global pressures and all
those other things it's the money in
your pocket absolutely Dentistry know
that the money in your pocket is what's
going to determine the next election and
the Relentless rise of interest rates
off the back of higher than expected and
persistent inflation is the thing that's
going to take money out of people's
pockets and quite possibly uh with
electrical consequence next year and
Richard Scenic today had two basic types
of argument one was to say look this is
happening everywhere but but the worry
in the city and I've talked to a few
businesses that actually Britain is
starting to get in the worst position
than other countries Richardson
mentioned America you know it was seven
days ago that U.S fed officials was
starting to float a kind of pause in
interest rate Rises because of the the
underlying data over over there and core
inflation which is what we saw going up
here today which makes the government's
argument that actually they're getting
inflation on the under control it makes
their argument difficult in the United
States in German the core inflation is
coming down and and so the the root of
global comparisons is is only of so much
utility for uh for for Rishi Cena the
other technique that he has is to say
label to spend more and that could push
up inflation now uh I think that's I
think many economists would agree that
that is potentially an issue labor
actually sort of slowed the path of that
additional spending and additional
borrowing in the last few days when it
comes to that uh comes to their green
project
um but but what people didn't hear a
great deal of is what the government are
going to do that's because there are no
easy answers because any big expensive
seed scheme that we saw the sort that we
saw with with Energy prices is a too
expensive and B will probably push up
inflation and therefore interest rates
and make the situation worse and and
that's the conundrum that both parties
have a neighbor can't can't have a a
clear answer to that uh particularly
what they can do is try and plan as much
blame for what's going on on the
conservative I think that's where that's
where the case is far more contestable
that's whether I think it's harder to
see that labor can blame the government
for for some of the things that are
going on here given the reason that the
UK is going in the wrong direction
um partly to do with um specific things
like the way that we went into furlough
the what the legacy of the fellow scheme
that it means that people are getting
back into office getting back into work
slower than in other countries or the
fact that we're more they can load the
blame which is the next door which they
they could do it it's I mean I'm not
sure whether labor are going to go out
full-throated and condemn the
fellowskeep that they agreed with at the
time or the fact that Britain is very
reliant on gas boilers much more so than
for instance in France so when Rishi
sinat blames Global problems actually
you know political advisors in his own
government admit that there are UK
specific factors that are the real
problem here that are not there are any
part due to government decision making
often government decision making at a
different point to deal with a different
crisis that was backed by the opposition
at the time so it's not clear that
there's a a as clear a dividing line
over that as there is uh uh as labor
would want there to be so that the kind
of blame game I think doesn't
necessarily help labor automatically on
the basis of the facts as I as I see
them but the but the problem is
Richardson hasn't yet developed a
language that is reassuring uh that
explains what might be able to be done
around the margins uh and how people can
deal with 400 pounds on people's
mortgages a month that is unsustainable
for almost everybody and and and there
just wasn't anything in the tone of the
Prime Minister or the substance really
that that acknowledged a sort of what
will be individual catastrophes on that
scale yeah and we're expecting a rate
rise aren't we coming through tomorrow
not nearly everybody in the city thinks
it's going to be at least a quarter of a
percent uh let's not make uh bones about
this it's going to be a key electoral
issue isn't it it is and um there is a
there is a group inside the conservative
party that would really love to blame
Andrew Bailey the governor of the bank
of England running arguments that he
started raising interest rates too late
and therefore Britain has to go go
further but because of what happened in
the Liz truss era essentially this
government Richie sunac has decided that
he cannot criticize and him and Jeremy
Hunt cannot criticize Andrew Bailey
because of the possibility of Market
turbulence additional Market turbulence
that that would that would cause so
blaming him is effectively off the table
at the moment for Tory politicians as
they cast around looking for uh for
villains in this but in the end I think
uh people will look uh at the situation
at what the government presents as as
what it's doing and and draw their own
conclusion